what's up guys we are confident today
we're playing a match to 21 points and
after each point we'll be adding one
piece of clothing this is gonna get
sweaty good luck good luck
[Applause]
we have chosen the hottest day of
Finnish summer to film this video if you
don't sweat enough in normal table
tennis this will get you sweaty
all right so the first item the brand
new Sensei t-shirt I'm looking forward
to putting this on
oh
yes
double shot I don't think I've ever done
this before I didn't say you still have
cooled down here
making the Sensei move for a change I'm
not feeling too happy about putting more
clothes on next point I'm going to lose
on purpose
[Applause]
foreign
all right
oh no this is this is the worst I hope
you guys are more excited to put this on
when you get it from our store then what
I am to put it on now this is where the
night messed up
but the design is very cool
tactic is working perfectly
yeah I don't know what I'm doing a
second pair of shorts
and no problem
three t-shirts on
[Music]
now he wasn't trying to get it on me he
just wanted to slap me my favorite
t-shirt who remembers this comment which
video this t-shirt has been used
makeup favorite shot the T-shirt works
actually
it's got the breathing hole
looking good no I'm not the time I have
warmed up I can start doing the footwork
let's see that
he's in a gang or something
it's a pizza from here but
this one's gonna be fun my favorite
Underpants
what what are you laughing now you've
got a problem with my outfit no no I
don't
time for some more Merch this is turning
out to be a great advert it's like
clothing for Infinity cap it's serious
angles
especially this one yeah me me it cost
me a summer look
yeah it's summer 2021 this is the look
to go for
that's why you never play with a cap on
I think that should work for me
look at him
I wouldn't want to face author like on a
dark Street
oh the Underpants
he's not so scary anymore
but again like in a weird way it
actually like Suits You
this is gonna ruin my fashion look now
you look like a baseball baseball
players yeah
the background's going well today oh
looking good
scared to serve anything now
throw it back to the sumo suit video
feel the same
[Music]
sorry my favorite one
[Music]
oh my God I can't see anything okay if
my footwork isn't fast now then it'll
never be fast
okay let's let's even it's out
enough of showing off the glasses off so
I'm getting a bit hot you want to put
some more clothes on I'd gladly put some
more clothes on
yes how can I missed it around the neck
glasses are on the net version I see
like a digital screen okay this is it
now
you can buy them for about 50. maybe in
20 years
oh now you're matching like brothers
oh nice oh oh toy hmm
nice purple thigh as well oh did you
want to come inside for me I feel like
I'm going to a big event suiting up very
weird Christmas party a very weird
Christmas fun I don't know who would
organize this sort of Christmas party
[Applause]
oh no this is where it gets bad I mean
my legs are already soaking wet this is
my least favorite item so far
with
[Music]
I wanted to make him pull and loose
almost the same color I mean it has to
be matching clothing
it's so hard to see the ball
just remember after we haven't even got
to the winter jackets yet I know
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
Double Hat Time
I don't want to lose
I'll let you give me a H let's hope
you're gonna use the spot I'd like if
the next item will be like a
refrigerator or something
[Music]
oh the scarf is loose
oh no good job look thanks ah yes
it doesn't look very breathable they're
like a really cool
I've got the everything
foreign
it's getting warm enough I'll actually
close the jacket I'll do that too
because too many things swinging around
yeah now it's better we've never been
this hot in my whole life
[Music]
sorry
all that work but nothing look at this
trick shot
no okay that's gonna make it hard you
look like you're prepared for like the
harshest winter season
only that can block from now on nothing
else yeah looking forward to these I was
getting a bit cold in the hand
what a shot I can make this sweat
dripping on my upper lip
not so fun anymore
how was this supposed to I'll put it on
you can you get your playing position
I'll I'll dress it up for you I I don't
trust you I'll tuck it in here he's got
like a tail
give us a wiggle
yes it feels a bit dangerous maybe you
put it like on your uh waist yeah
you tied his legs
that was on purpose I don't want to put
another jacket on no problem it's just a
motorcycle jacket
pretty much finally it's over
and the new Sensei collection with this
really cool design is now available at
Pancho link below go get yours from
there